and ponder the question
what if
time
space
reality
excitement i am the watcher
i am your guide through these vast new
realities look buddy anything sounds
impressive when you use that voice i am
the sin master i am your guide through
these vast inconsistencies
see what if roll commercials we're not
even out of the opening credits yet also
why the question mark marvel i mean if
you drop the ellipses it could be a
complete sentence but once you add those
it indicates there's more of a sentence
to come which means the punctuation
should follow the sentence this should
either be what if what if or if you want
to get really freaky and indicate the
return ellipses what if this just looks
like a question mark that accidentally
has four downstairs tittles that's right
i said tittles at humanity's darkest
hour a skinny kid from brooklyn became
captain america using your precious
little storytelling time to rehash
movies we've already seen the show isn't
called what was marvel bring on swole
carter already agent carter wouldn't you
be more comfortable in the booth that's
the moment
that created a new universe except
things must have already diverged
because in the version we've seen steve
was already in the harder better faster
stronger machine and this kernel looked
a lot more like stranix from under siege
[Music]
originally this explosion happens after
steve has been transformed why would
penny's arbitrary decision to choose
ringside seats to the buffening result
in a change in the timing of a plan that
had already been set in motion long
before a said decision was made am i
going to point out every tiny
discrepancy between this and the first
avenger only time will tell stark you go
in what are you crazy i push the buttons
i'm the buns gun the church i grew up in
had a buttons guy he wore all sorts of
weird buttons on his suit he seemed fine
until one day he brought a piece of
wooden axe to service and started
chopping in front of the congregation
without warning while shouting about
pruning the evil branches keep an eye on
stark is all i'm saying agent carter
what are you doing this is our only
chance now is it though you still have
all the super juice and the machine
itself appears to be intact i feel like
somebody really wanted a new timeline
but didn't put the time in to make it
all line up start don't do this is that
bradley whitford was he in the original
cat movie you think you can just add
brad to your little tv show to make him
feel more important whitford is a
treasure and i'm setting you for not
having him in the movie too and yes i
know he played the same role in a short
that was attached to the home release of
iron man 3 but do you think i watched
that i barely even watched iron man 3.
did it work and then some you won't be
needing those hills anymore she never
needed them ever also she's hulked out
here so much that that cami should be
shredded most clothes wouldn't have
stood a chance and buff carter should be
in the buff carter right now for
authenticity reasons of course women
aren't soldiers they sure as hell don't
fight on the front lines you might break
a nail colonel flynn survives this
seriously colonel flynn is such an
[ __ ] in this show they might as well
have named him colonel [ __ ] colonel
hole colonoscopy not according to
colonel flynn weapons great [ __ ]
funny reveal but you do realize this
means that this room had at least 15 of
these giant weights and she's thrown
this many of them into this poor
defenseless wall kind of a dick move if
you ask me which you did when you
clicked on the video so this one's on
you uh could be worse flynn could stick
you on one of those uso tours wear a
crazy costume being told to smile 10
times a day why isn't peggy doing the
morale boosting rounds like steve did in
the original timeline if anything and
not saying this is right wouldn't the
army brass see a woman as even more
morale boosting for the men on the front
line bucky
bucky i'd hope perhaps naively that
crossing into a new space-time continuum
would be enough to save us from the
whole mad about bucky subplot that
stalked us for over a decade we haven't
talked about this animation style yet
but i'm pretty much hating it it's like
rotoscoping got cell shading pregnant
after an intense three-way with some
binary code and then drove out to the
middle of the uncanny valley for the
birth then why do you try so hard to
hide it so hard more like not hard
enough this ancient mystical artifact of
immeasurable power is kept safe and
secure in a box inside a wall guarded by
one elderly bearded gentleman and can be
accessed by pushing one [ __ ] button
heck howard stark could have even
completed that mission button guy call
back this doesn't concern you you're
lucky to be in the room title of my sex
tape why did stark redesign the costume
in this very tasteful shade of god save
the queen yes carter is british but she
still works for the u.s right or is a
female captain america just that one
step too far
that was brilliant let's give it another
go is the show insinuating that captain
crunches is trying to figure out these
things for the first time in actual
enemy combat or is that just the rush
nature of trying to squeeze a whole
story into 30 minutes either way
carter's new look is amazing and it's
worth pointing out that marvel is
directly indicating that the cultural
idea of female beauty could use a little
beefing up i for one am loving it and
this sin removal is for letting peggy be
completely union jacked also if peggy
looks in a mirror at some point and says
that is great britain's ass i'm giving
back all the sins are you seeing this
who is she talking to the action in this
episode and this scene in particular is
easier to follow and of better quality
than 90 of the action we're presented
with in the damn movies another sin off
bad guy cracks his neck calmly as an
indication that he's super tough cliche
exactly is that it why does everyone
keep underestimating how important the
tesseract is red skull went to all that
trouble to find the damn thing only to
immediately lose it by allowing it to be
transported by these clowns instead of a
battalion of tanks i trust you know what
to do with that
oh i know exactly what to do with this
well i'm glad somebody does because it's
been over a decade now and i still don't
have a clue what the damn thing does
does super soldier serum also provide
actual physical skills like jumping a
motorcycle through a fence i get the
strength and dexterity thing but
wouldn't you still need actual
proprioceptive training beyond the
inherent physical qualities what are
they just matrix that into your brain as
well
what is the point of this excellent
vantage point if you wait until after
the enemies breached the gates and
killed three of your comrades did your
friends here hurt you did they steal
your bratwurst from the communal fridge
send air support
now admittedly this iron giant man is
very cool but wouldn't it have been
cooler to let this be captain carter's
story feels like we're stepping on her
moment in the spotlight by allowing
steve to swoop in and be the hero in
this timeline as well well then we
better start dancing
[Music]
captain carter's dancing looks strangely
like murder oh
i miss a good whiskey then why did you
immediately ruin it by putting ice in it
i'm still that skinny kid from brooklyn
now just in a big metal suit a big metal
suit powered by an infinite power source
that's capable of destroying tanks and
basically anything in its path yeah you
got nothing brooklyn you're more than
the suit the suit is nothing without the
man inside you're my butt
hey barnes stole a jeep grand theft snog
blocking honestly i have no idea why
bucky and these other five guys are even
needed on this mission if the 60 million
dollar super soldier in the infinity
stone powered suit of armor can't handle
it i fail to see how steven's other love
interest and his buddies are gonna make
the difference something about this
smells as fresh as three day old fish
or maybe you're just afraid of trains
this dig about bucky being afraid of
trains is very specific and only really
makes sense if peggy knows that bucky
was lost and presumed dead after he was
thrown from a train in the other
timeline which she most certainly
shouldn't look at the size of that zip
line are you telling me the best plan
you could come up with with getting on
the train was to set up a thousand foot
eye zip line stretching over a mile and
then time it perfectly base jumping
makes more sense than this and base
jumping never makes sense
thanks you almost ripped my arm off
you said the hydra stomper was
indestructible it is
his name
is steve rogers not the hydra stomper
hold your horses there peggy to be fair
they were specifically arguing about the
suit being indestructible no one is
under the impression that steve is too
soon too bad i will tell you nothing
he told me everything
implied torture tactics oh you rap
scallion come on howard we might need
someone to push a button button guy call
back
ours was funnier if this is the big
hydra hideout why does its external
defenses consist of only half a dozen
soldiers an uncoated gate release button
and zero sentries where are the damn
tanks where are the snipers why is
castle who needs a plan i have a shield
a shield is not a plan what if howard
stark was excellent at tv since the
champion of hydra has risen your super
powerful ultimate champion world
dominating being from another dimension
sure looks suspiciously like an octopus
so no plan b in the event that you were
unable to communicate with this extra
dimensional creature thus being unable
to immediately bend it to your will you
just get squished alrighty then stark
was right indestructible
steve
steve how thoughtful of evil hydra
agents to keep steve in the same room as
his super suit despite the dozens of
other rooms that are no doubt available
in this castle german efficiency man you
can't beat it now where's peggy she drew
the high card this suit could give out
at any minute and bucky thinks up is
enough specificity to allow steve to get
to peggy in the shortest amount of time
possible how the rate is spreading
how the [ __ ] did she manage to
extrapolate that one it hasn't even
filled this room yet what makes her
think it will continue to grow to
continent devouring size excuse me i'm
just gonna grab my sword of unbelievable
convenience
red green blue who paints the bottom
blue the blue man group the smurfs
eiffel 65 shall i continue don't tell me
the american playboy
was that a clitoris joke because i think
there's a clitoris joke in there but i'm
having a really difficult time locating
it
did you miss me for the second time in
this outing the man has come to save the
day and rescue the female hero did no
one at marvel realize this was a dumb
ass idea which fundamentally undermines
the impact of this female captain
america's story where steve watches
the war
ended
almost 70 years ago that's a strange way
of saying who's steve rogers also
apparently everything else went exactly
the same even though you changed the
timeline guess there's no carter fly
effect who's gonna tell ashton i observe
all that transpires here but i do not
cannot will not interfere then is there
really any point to you at all
hey steve rogers
steve steve steve
steve
go get him steve his name
is steve rogers
time that is black panther space that's
captain marvel reality that is iron man
ah we're being flunked through a
tournament of alternative universe space
shards this is so unsafe behold the
triangle of convenience of course you
would be humble classic star-lord
putting classic in front of anyone's
name also known as a classic sin
t'challa has unwaveringly balanced
korath on one shoulder as if he's a baby
about to be burped sure he works out and
practices hand-to-hand combat but he's
just a normal man and hauling dead
weight around should not be this easy
not one of these well-armored fighters
decides to shoot out t'challa's knees
not one though our hero's destiny might
lie in the stars above the beginning of
his journey was much more
down to earth previously on black
panther also is living in a rich
technologically advanced fantasyland
like wakanda really more down to earth i
mean it's on earth i guess but still
it's [ __ ] wakanda does this really
look like peter quilty y'all sure i
don't know all humans look alike to me
that's racist well my home is built on
an ancient vibranium media right secret
spilling kids but why stop at one world
huh
when we can show you all of them this
kid is zipped up into orbit by a
kid-snatching alien and doesn't shed a
single tear for the loss of the
relationships he leaves behind why is
t'challa so chill about his impending
abduction your money is no good here
please no seriously we only take cash
then why not just start with that saying
your money's no good here and we only
take cash are two very different things
it's implication which is not something
drax would ever do he's just brutally
honest also how are they able to get
just about everyone back to voice their
characters they played in the live
action films we couldn't get dave
bautista to voice drax was he too busy
pitching stupor too remember nebula is
just a cartoon remember nebula is just a
cartoon remember nebula's when i was
young yondu attempted to return me to
wakanda but
it had been destroyed t'challa knows
nebulan works with her father from time
to time she should already know this
story no i get that we don't know this
story but there has to be a less sinful
way to get it exposited to us and then
you ask but even if there was wouldn't
you send the exposition anyways and yes
yes we absolutely would standing
directly in this blinding light beam
never have been any good at saying no to
you kid this is probably the first time
in the history of parenting that never
saying no has resulted in a responsible
adult i mean if you consider an adult
who robs people blind responsible so
yeah you should say no to your kids
sometimes parents the collector's got a
famous kink for exotic flora and fauna
dendrophilia and no there's nothing
wrong with a healthy fetish i just love
saying dendrophilia stop i thought we
were faking it shouting your plan at
this volume near the people you are
trying to trick ravagers will start a
riot drawing the attention of the black
order we have a situation all units
report to our position all units report
because one guy was chucked across a
courtyard that was hardly a riot and the
only reason this works is because of the
this works cliche amazing i i have no
notes a perfect plan no notes how about
the glaringly obvious question of where
will we find the embers of genesis
inside the [ __ ] maze the show tells
us the answer is to accidentally run
into a duck that gives directions
perfect plan my ass oh my dearest nebula
aren't you aside for a sore
i forgive me i couldn't help myself the
collector would be a marvel at tv since
sure most everyone is seeing t'challa
find living collections and thinking
about their story or purpose but i'm
over here wondering how the collector
feeds them all or cleans out their cages
or what is the food bill for this many
living creatures my guess he's
compensating for something big man
marvel is really trying hard to make
howard the duck of thing in this
universe i like getting weird as much as
the next guy but i still have scars from
trying to wrap my little kid brain
around leah thompson begging for some
duct tape i don't need those wounds
opened up again you know i can find them
the cosmic floor down the hall says the
duck in a moving prison maze who somehow
knows where a very specific item is
located talking loudly discharging a
weapon having no general plan of where
you're going i mean the list of reasons
why t'tala's doing a terrible job just
grows and grows you know what they say
when you're out of luck always go duck
or my personal favorite if it don't
quack don't give a [ __ ] the ravagers
it's a diversion only one person of this
highly trained deadly gang knows what
the ravagers look like ah yes wakanda
tech so advanced that it glows like
daylight to really hammer home that the
necklace matches the vehicle t'challa is
so lucky too because the model of his
necklace includes the glow even brighter
mode if he hesitates to follow the
plotline
i mean t'challa is correct but he can't
possibly know that yet the homing beacon
could have been sent years ago and
wakanda could have still been destroyed
both things can be true you don't belong
down there with them you belong up here
with us with your family justifying
kidnapping all a distraction providing
me the necessary cover to obtain this
the embers of genesis but the show won't
bother us with showing us how she
actually did it that would be just silly
the collector would be smart enough to
remove anything from a person that could
be used as a weapon but of course he
doesn't here because reasons i liked
that thing you said about not locking
people in cages that's what it took to
convince karina not the thousands of
individuals that were kidnapped and
locked in cages before t'challa it's
good she came to her senses and took a
stand but damn it took a long time to
get there there's plenty more we can
play with observe collector fans prepare
yourselves for several minutes of op
weapons in fan fiction fighting i warn
you so you can get your mental
masturbatory sock ready a dagger forced
in dark matter taken from the ruler of
the dark elves reminding me that thor
the dark world is a thing that exists
just a reminder as t'challa somehow
manages to launch himself backwards a
hundred feet do the splits mid-air and
snatch a crown off ahead that he's just
human these perfectly symmetrical
chaotic eyebrows don't you love how the
wall of weapons fire reduces to a few
shots once the enemies are in sight also
our heroes can escape and have a few
boss battles my point is if you have an
army of bad guys blasting the [ __ ] out
of a place one second why would they
stop when they turn the corner first if
yondu had just put the whistle missile
through the collector's head this would
be done by now second did he just knock
off hella's helmet and it shatters sort
of lame powerful helmet takes a tumble
off a noggin and disintegrates see kids
this is why you never eat watermelon
seeds do you think this can contain me
at this point i'll believe whatever you
show me thanos is decent nebula is a
blonde pressing buttons on an arm cuff
you've never used before can open a very
specific door to the nearest nifty jail
cell none of this matters because it's
not in the timeline i've been investing
in in i [ __ ] hate it the collector
magically has the bracelet back on that
yondu took off of him i was the one who
told you i wanted to see the world all
you did was show me the universe oh i
see we've arrived at the last act where
conflict simply fades and we're eating
the crumbs of the remaining resolution
to the story i don't want crumbs i want
a sandwich
where you want to be
that's the question isn't it better
question how did he know which button
was the show me the earth button on a
wakandan ship but that's a story for
another day is it a story that will
almost entirely be people saying trust
me this thing we're doing is super hard
and then skipping over how they managed
to actually do the hard things because i
just watched that episode i'm not
interested in round two i see marvel has
learned nothing from their titling
mistakes in captain america civil war
there was an idea
to bring together a group of remarkable
people i know i've heard the speech if
your characters are getting tired of the
recaps and references imagine how your
audience must feel about them also
finishing someone else's sentence people
need to quit thinking that it's cute
because it's not it's just [ __ ]
annoying for the initial person talking
and anyone listening to the conversation
letting your signature iron man scene be
an homage to iron man 2 and i know
that's the time frame of when all this
is taking place but what if there was no
iron man 2. did i ever tell you about
this one time i actually recruited a
russian assassin to join my american
covert ops team sounds like an
interesting story certainly an idea
worth exploring perhaps in a movie
marvel should get right on that 10 years
ago then you should know i'm not afraid
of a big swing i wish this show wasn't
afraid of a big swing then we might get
some story lines a little more
interesting than what if this character
was replaced by this character sir i'm
going to have to ask you to exit the
donut is stark truly inside the donut
though i mean is the hole in a ring
donut truly a part of its whole or is it
simply the acknowledgement of an absence
of donut was it ever truly whole to
start with is it more or less whole with
or without its hole damn it marvel give
us the answers we truly crave
what should just do to me i'm pretty
sure romanov just poked you without your
explicit consent since you're about to
die horrible death stark we'll take care
of the sitting don't you worry i'm the
watcher hold on are we getting treated
to two narrated exposition dumps in the
first five minutes jeffrey right on this
wasn't me i know that but shield has
protocols so my hands like yours are
tied actually i don't understand this at
all romanov will take the syringe to dr
ross and find out that the serum was
never even injected into stark this
should have been easily detected by
shield csi or whatever they have it
should have resulted in further
investigation into the matter they are
charging roman off with a crime and
wiping their hands way too quickly glad
real life authorities never do that
right
right here mind holding these for me of
course huh
what even though the guard is only
fooled by this for 1 19 of a second he
is still fooled by it for precisely 1
19th of a second too long i never did
get what he sees in her sure she can
land a punch but only cause people don't
expect it that's black widowest it's
always fun to watch black widow kick
some ass but once again we have an
action set piece with a large group of
guards attacking the protagonist one
maximum two at a time instead of
immediately overwhelming them with sheer
superior numbers
[Music]
that doesn't sound ominous at all it's
been happening all night the artifact
has a bit of an attitude or maybe it's
just a storm also no one can lift it not
even jackson he does crossfit do you
mean chris crossfit jackson do you know
he's also vegan and that he doesn't own
a television great guy super humble he's
a caucasian male mid-20s with
really great hair
excuse me it's an accurate description
no it isn't yes chris hemsworth is about
as close to being objectively beautiful
as his humanly or as guardianly possible
but fury is right to be outraged here
great hair is not a remotely helpful or
appropriate descriptor he's making a
move on the hammer one shot one kill sir
to say the word why go for a kill shot
at all wasn't the idea to find out more
about the hammer from whoever came to
retrieve it i swear i didn't shoot
your arrow would indicate otherwise nick
fury would be excellent at tv sins this
doesn't make any sense
i don't slip
i don't miss fire vanity what's the word
on our intruder did from an arrow how
did a damn arrow kill thor he's a god
the man was hit with a [ __ ] neutron
star for crying out loud an arrow [ __ ]
off with your nonsense
even while rotting he smells like
lavender really
this sudden obsession with thor's beauty
and appealing olfactory presence is
understandable but slightly creepy i
don't remember anyone sniffing him the
first time around maybe that's the real
sin here dr ross not sure if you
remember me but i used to sound like
scarlett johansson and now i sound like
lake bell doing an impersonation of
scarlett johansson well your injector's
clean
and there's no traces of lethal
pathogens of any kind what the college
medical clinic resident told me after my
sdd test somehow makes its way into this
episode
what was the point of asking her if she
was in a secure location if you're just
gonna go ahead with the damn news anyway
also if you're gonna inform someone that
their friend and colleague has just been
murdered maybe don't preface it with a
quippy i've got bad news and worst news
go get em boss professional sideline
cheerleaders you would do best to kneel
before a god we don't really do that
here no matter who or what you are
unless you're the queen of england but
other than that no one well other than
the person you're proposing marriage to
but other than those two people no one
well some people like to kneel in front
of important stature you know what fury
we actually knew quite a bit
i am loki crown prince of asgard the
rightful king of yerton
this rings on for some time and i have
no idea why i know it's played for
comedy but in reality there's no reason
to allow phone to continue to ring over
clearly important conversation if the
intent is to pick up the call then pick
it up and excuse yourself damn it if you
have no intention of picking it up then
decline the call takes a special kind of
[ __ ] to allow a phone to persistently
ring in this hugely distracting manner
excuse me for just a second hello a
multiverse of infinite diversity and
innumerable outcomes yet in this
timeline banner still ends up in the
exact same glass corridor at the exact
same time colonel ross and his friends
turn up what's in the box
such insolence will not be tolerated
insolence does what's in the box have an
unfortunate translation in asgardian i
mean unless you're talk oh
but he can't die
he can't die
he can't he can we are not allies
then let me help you um fury he just
said you weren't allies in case you
confused it with manasseh wait is this
the only manassas in the whole world
then i guess there truly is no good
reason to include the state in this
subtitle i'm not telling you my password
why not
steve steve steve i heart steve
704. this is a perfectly fine password
to use for personal accounts and such
but it's absolutely ludicrous that
coulson would use it for work as well
yes in theory it should only ever be
known by him but i also know that
chael's entire i.t department would
never be able to look coulson in the eye
wow good one colson what what does
colson mean what his reluctance to share
his password was at least partly because
it was embarrassing as all hell so why
the surprise at black widow's
understandable reaction for some
inexplicable reason our mystery
assailant who has been doing a fantastic
job of covertly taking out earth's
mightiest heroes and hawkeye decides to
switch to this very noisy and aggressive
beatdown for black widow do they know
the third act resolution is coming
because they really shouldn't furious
it's all about hope i can't think of a
single reason why black widow would
choose to communicate this vital
breakthrough in a way that is so vague
and open to interpretation she could
have just as easily said hope van dyne
and that would have been plenty enough
for fury to go on with no chance of it
coming off as a vague platitude but
heaven forbid were robbed of one last
twist for the sake of believable
decision making if it isn't hank pym
hank has killed everyone else with a
surprise attack but for fury he walks it
behind him as a normal sized human so he
can talk about his motive that makes
sense you took everything from me i
wanted you to hurt wrath in this montage
of murder you can see that hank pym was
the projectile that hit bruce back at
the university but at the time we were
shown a scope moving around and taking
aim at banner mistakenly leading us to
believe it was one of ross's
trigger-happy soldiers but if this was
pym all along who shot the gun good
evening my loyal subjects so with
earth's mightiest heroes and hawkeye out
of the way loki is free to rule humanity
with little resistance but why earth
with thor out of the way couldn't he
have taken over asgard wasn't that
always the plan i believe that in this
universe as in every other hope never
dies
except in this universe she definitely
did oh we're back to being metaphorical
see easy mistake
time being wasted
space hang out reality is that i've
already hit the skip intro prompt
because this intro was boring the first
time i saw it let alone the fourth we
have watched how one moment one choice
watcheration so much wateration what if
the best of intentions
has very strange consequences if you're
going to doctor the wording for puns
don't do that ancient one at a time
thing you really need to throw a few
supreme turns of phrase in there to
really make it all even steven the
question is how many more do scissor
doors too many people learn the wrong
lessons from back to the future evening
handsome this i just pulled it out of
the dryer what does this even mean how
would putting an item of clothing in the
dryer make it any less impressive do
most people in new york wear wet clothes
you promised me creme brulee
i suspect we can do a little better than
that for someone who brags about putting
a suit in a dryer i'm a little afraid to
find out what doctor strange considers a
little better i just stick with the
creme brulee doc she's not gonna find
the frosted animal cookie blizzard as
charming as you do strange slows his
vehicle down and the guy behind him
rear-ends him in a skid steven's car
then does a full turn significantly
broadsides a pole does another turn and
a half and still somehow breaks through
the rock guard barrier with enough
momentum to launch 10 feet out over the
cliff joe doesn't know how to law of
conservation of energy correctly in this
universe steven strange didn't lose his
hands
but his heart roll commercial show title
is completely invalid he didn't lose his
hands before he lost his use of them and
that's not his heart that's his dead
girlfriend in a box and the director
said let's do that mystical apple eating
thing again so the audience will know
we're [ __ ] for only changing the
things we want to in the timeline
because callbacks steven strange
could not let go of the past wonderful
instead of christine being ignored under
used and wasted this time we're going to
have her be completely fridged for
motivational purposes such progress
sorry but this is now my favorite
t-shirt stealing what are you doing up i
needed the little saucer as well calling
it your little sorcerer you're being
delightful i must owe someone a muffin
basket for this personality shift
calling it your muffin basket well this
is shaping up to be a night to remember
we find out eventually it doesn't matter
but how does strange go back to stop
this from happening and still get
rear-ended at the exact same place in
the road with the same pole and same
weak ass guard wall why wait till the
second try to go ahead and have google
maps find a route that i don't know
doesn't involve the death cliff and one
job strange also just going to go ahead
and add 10 sins because this groundhog
day sorcery goes on for all the some
time
we'll go we'll dance i promise you we
will have a good time
[Music]
no what even happens here she has some
sort of medical event like maybe a heart
thing it's clear the universe needs her
to die but if it's already going for
cardiac arrest and an otherwise healthy
young woman shouldn't strange know he
can't change anything at this point how
do you go back in time to avoid random
health issue that could happen anywhere
also they made it there to dance how did
they do that does the universe have a
bit of leeway on the timeline once the
christine must die window anyone have a
direct number for the tva and now we're
back in the water below the same exact
cliff again you went back to trying to
drive the same route i guess there's
nothing you can do sometimes people just
pick a hill to die
[Music]
including one death of one dr christine
palmer fatalistic news position fatal is
position also not only does the universe
decide to take out numerous people to
get to christine but the local news
decides that she's worth soloing as an
immediate eulogy is she that famous in
new york city why does this keep
happening maybe because you keep coming
back to this point in time maybe he
can't change the outcome regardless but
you'd think strange would attempt one
trip to a time prior to this night do
you want to talk
maybe put on some music
maybe warner about the car that's about
to crash into her that you know is
coming
[Music]
no good evening doctor strange
are you having car trouble oh snap more
like the [ __ ] one am i right also why
is she just coming now her and wong made
it clear that [ __ ] around with time
travel is a bad idea so if the ancient
one could come to him and prevent all of
this why would she wait this long
her death is an absolute point in time
in this universe you mean because it
certainly didn't happen this way and the
other one maybe strange shouldn't be
looking at time travel but should be
looking at multiverse oh
there is no hope here right so then does
he just what come back with you to your
timeline live out the rest of this
timeline go to one of the numerous
timelines he's already created and what
timeline are you even from how does any
of this even work where did you come
from where does he go where did you come
from plot and lie joe library
hello
you know books reading
knowledge that's racist the lost books
sorcerer reading do you mind sharing a
tentacle or two attempting to share
someone's tentacle even if you're asking
for explicit consent it's kind of
strange strange strange survives this
when red skull didn't
what happened well even though you got
strewn about by a giant octopus monster
not only are you not showing any wear or
tear the bruce you had earlier on your
forehead is also miraculously gone a man
does not suffer like this for his own
glory
[Laughter]
yeah humans are much more likely to
suffer for others than themselves super
unselfish this species if they won't
surrender their power i'll take it
let's start small so this episode is
basically what if doctor strange
murdered an insane amount of fantastical
creatures well that's fun for the kids
every one of these creatures feels like
an inside joke i'm probably missing it's
like lego batman all over again and i'm
all like haha can you imagine if there
was a condiment-based villain and
everyone else was like well there is and
i was like yeah comic books totally why
did the dragon turn them all dragon face
but the garden gnome didn't give him a
fishing pole and a visible butt crack
you use magic to remain frozen for
centuries nope that's a different disney
property everything is a different
disney property he wasn't even the only
doctor strange in this universe i would
give all the sense back if we get a time
cop face melt when the two versions of
steven strange meet
what was in that whiskey dude people's
faces are inking off and you're cracking
wise why do you think you're healing the
world with your comedy yes just think of
me as an echo
i drew upon the power of the dark
dimension to split the timeline
to split you sure i guess but you split
the strange who was already trying to
change the past into half who continued
on that journey and then half that went
back in time and forgot all that stuff
just say yada yada next time and save us
all the headache i mean we're gonna send
you either way but i prefer the
non-headache way two timelines i doubt
that's the simplest or smartest thing to
do steven strange would be magical at tv
sins how would you find him
he's found me convenient timing of evil
strange finding not as evil strange is
convenient
hello episode is 14 someone saying hello
and randomly adele's favorite episode
don't you dare lie to me i am you yeah i
know here's a what if for you what if
marvel took one of their films that
somehow didn't end in same versus same
and decided to make it into a tv episode
that did end that way marvel's got a
marvel i guess episode ends with one
minute and 50 seconds of sorcery pew
pewing
[Music]
i'm pumped this [ __ ] came back around
marvel [ __ ] studios but after 40
seconds of this intro the caffeine wore
off so i'm giving it one sin for the
usual intro credit nonsense and five for
inducing the roller coaster of emotions
i just experienced
time space
reality it's more than a linear path for
the love of odin bernard is lost in his
[ __ ] again or is it arnold i don't
know i gave up on westworld long before
it decided to not give us any satisfying
answers but jeffrey wright has doubled
down on these types of cryptic
characters so i'm giving him a sin i'm
giving hbo a sin and i'm giving
marvelous in respectively it's a prism
of endless possibility so it sins are
parallel its sides are flat and marvel
is definitely going to use this later to
explain away some [ __ ] when we all
try to make sense of it i am the watcher
this half-hearted attempt to make
rockwell cannon in the mcu by suggesting
that somebody's watching me
then this is coming
he's coming i guess this whole bifrost
space laser elevator through the stairs
wasn't enough to establish which
infinity saga moment we were being
dropped into so bruce banner has to say
this line presumably to the audience
come on big guy time to go green i get
that he's wearing this outfit because he
didn't have any other clothes but i'm
genuinely shocked he couldn't resist the
matching fingerless gloves now i have to
say that this scene does not contain a
break dance
come on come on
actual video footage of cinemasins staff
trying to coax a joke out of her sick
mind somehow makes its way into this
episode show wants me to believe the
zombie versions of iron man doctor
strange and wong are somehow more
effective in this fight than they would
be normally i assume it's because
they're hangry i can't believe it that
the walking dead has managed to actually
infect disney yeah me either go you'll
be safe with them with the bug that just
ate the dangerous saliva-filled head of
a zombie no thank you who are you all
that's left well that's just a dumb
superhero name like too many great
catastrophes this one sprang from a
place of love
and hope no one will be seated while the
resident creepy voyeur of the mcu
interrupts the show to deliver
unnecessary exposition and puns janet
van dyne contracted a quantum virus that
corrupted her brain does throwing the
word quantum in front of virus satiate
our bloodlust for backstory and
continuity no this raises more questions
than the time i sprained my quantum
ankle running away from my brother after
punching him in his quantum balls alas
hope vandyn's long-awaited family
reunion was not to be i mean technically
the family was reunited it was just
violence and viscera rather than hugs
and hummus see the problem with the hand
press to a steamy pane of glass cliche
is that when the sound is turned down
i'm not sure if this is a death scene or
a sex scene or since it's zombies i
guess it could be both setting scenes on
the golden gate bridge is so overplayed
that the audience couldn't care less
about what's going on here whether it be
mutants apes or zombies it's a loss
we're all prepared for at this point
kind of like ohio because once earth's
mightiest heroes joined the infected
no one else stood a chance
unless of course they knew the rules for
someone that likes to watch he sure does
interrupt a lot you're invited here to
observe not give notes larry why would
experienced adventurers land their plane
on a bridge where they could be easily
surrounded it's almost like the writers
wanted to skip over the avengers using
strategy to handle their flesh-eater
situation so that a walking dead fan
could finally live out their undead
crossover fantasy new york home of the
mets the chrysler building those ladies
from sex in the city picking three
things that would make scott lang say oh
yeah those are in new york i know those
if you can make it here you can make it
anywhere the whole make it anywhere
cliche might be a bit of a stretch most
new yorkers get confused by the wilds of
connecticut do i really have to be
wearing this as an adult do you really
have to ask that question i presume
they're talking about the eulogy she
gave for her aunt which is a pretty dark
easter egg to throw in this otherwise
comedic video this web job looks as
structurally sound as the one made by
that spider the scientist dose with lsd
well just when you thought things
couldn't get any worse
we gotta go to jersey you know what [ __ ]
you marvel i hate new jersey just as
much as any decent american but that was
completely unprovoked you saved that for
a real threat like ohio all right
everybody it's grand central unless the
show is claiming some butterfly effect
nonsense has rerouted the train lines
you need to go to penn station if you
want to train to new jersey uh splitting
up do you guys just not have horror
movies and wakanda we don't need them we
have american reality shows boom goes
the dynamite all of these [ __ ]
almost die because they couldn't resist
telling peter parker to go [ __ ] himself
no happy you can't be this silly before
you descend into the zombie-infested
bowels of grand central station when
earlier you were this serious about a
t-shirt happy a truly unfortunate name
at a time like this parents let this be
a reminder to name your children
something that makes some [ __ ] sense
asking us to believe spidey could gain
traction in his adult footy pajama
costume
all the other avengers have kept their
abilities despite their zombie
transformations then hawkeye misses two
out of three shots he takes at sharon
marvel is definitely playing least
favorites
that was your friend sorry about that
i should be sad but i'm not after
watching falcon in the winter soldier i
can't tell if that was a comedic quip or
if bucky was unpacking some seriously
nuanced feelings about his relationship
with sam show wants me to laugh crying i
will not do it i will
not
there are so many deus ex vestus moments
in the show that i'm pretty sure the
cloak of levitation is the strongest
avenger
whoever made the glass for this subway
needs to be sued for poor craftsmanship
if a brittle zombie can punch through
the manufacturers something up pretty
badly so the list now is one survive two
sue i think you've had enough cap i'm
not gonna send the fact that we see the
avengers get infected in san francisco
earlier and it seems they've all made
their flight back to new york but i am
gonna send the fact that half of them
were at grand central station the exact
moment the normies showed up as if this
was just part of their daily commute
bucky you know how the shield works
shoot the legs
[Music]
i suppose everyone feels really
confident about avoiding zombie saliva
at this point but why would flying
directly into the mouth of the creature
that can turn you into a walking
nightmare be a wise move at any time she
gets what's coming to her is what i'm
saying i guess this is the end of the
line i'm beginning to doubt that
sebastian stan even had to record a
voiceover for this show it's like they
recycled his dialogue from all his other
mcu appearances hope
i think you're in trouble hope exploding
through sharon causes this wound when
all the flying through fools she was
doing earlier didn't leave so much as a
scratch can we really take that risk
it's not risk
it's hope and anyone who's seen a zombie
movie knows that that's the key to
survival actually it's both risky and
hopeful and anyone who's seen zombieland
knows the key to survival is cardio and
twinkies the cardio helps you survive
the twinkies well looks like our drive
cars just got pulled bucky says
something to remind us he was in world
war ii cliche oh come on oh it's not
your fault lying smile
smile for me okay sure use your last
moments to say something that'll really
get up instead of you know figuring out
a way to disarm yourself so you don't
kill everyone with your smallness
largeness why is no one even slightly
concerned about the giant zombie hope is
about to turn into i know what you're
thinking that futurama did it better
what i wouldn't give to get chewed out
by that old grump one last time god did
it again zombie pun no one thinks it
would be a good idea to inform scott
that his partner and love interest hope
fandine just died moments ago hey just
let him continue on with the dad jokes
sergeant barnes you will not find
what you're looking for even if we
ignore the super obvious shift in tone
at the end of this statement not a
single one of these schmucks asks a
simple why bucky just saunters off into
the next plot point bucky is looking for
transport and what looks like a morgue
according to these security logs we're
not the first to respond to vision
signal first rule of hiding the fact
that you've been luring people to their
desks for the purposes of feeding your
zombie girlfriend delete the security
logs for a hyper-intelligent superbot
vision is terrible at subterfuge he's
been keeping him alive to feed his
zombie bride alive and bride don't
really rhyme but bucky's flow had just
enough rhythm to make this freestyle
work and to that i say these characters
are not treating this moment with the
appropriate seriousness her powers are
too strong they've resisted the
treatment oh
i must atone for what i have done but i
cannot bring myself to leave her vision
then immediately does leave her by
offing himself also he definitely should
but i don't think he has to atone right
[ __ ] now and i don't care if the
writers think that the power of vision's
roboner is so strong that it can explain
away his motivations for pretty much
everything he's done since captain
america civil war do you think you can
fly this he asks the man who is already
seated in the pilot seat and confidently
pressing buttons context clues spidey
context clues i don't think i can lose
another friend today
so
avenge us here teenager you solve it
phew right at the end they slip in the
mountain of roach crawling zombies
cliche that we all have come to adore
and respect yes we send it every time
but we haven't yet taken this intro to
task for breaking the one minute rule
yet by the time we get to the actual
episode one minute and 45 seconds have
passed almost two full minutes of
preliminary logo lashing and title
trouncing before we see a frame of new
content we've said it before and we'll
say it again you get one minute tv shows
anymore and cindy brings down the sin
hammer is it cool if i take a picture
with you yes but it is not okay to carry
your camera around with a full zoom
erection at the ready like this and
here's another minute of just repeating
the beginning of iron man with almost no
changes it's like my dad always said if
you didn't add any new wrinkles why did
you have to re-iron man in fact the only
thing the show removes is the ever
relevant myspace joke i'm about to move
you out of my top eight marvel
it appears as if random soldier guy gets
taken out with some sort of shotgun with
huge shot pellets and a wide dispersion
and my question is how did tony not
catch even a scratch from any of that
shot that went through these holes also
it appears they're traveling in the
middle of the day so how would the light
source be low enough for this kind of
light dispersion the angle puts it right
here which honestly looks to be below
the mountainous horizon but it looks
really cool so i guess science yeah
granted along with luke's binary sunset
and the falling dude hitting the
propeller on the titanic this is one of
the greatest shots in movie history but
the more you show it the more you risk
annoying us it's like that one
well-endowed guy in gym class who spends
as much time naked as possible in the
locker room we get it man you can put
that thing away now we just watched a
handball instructional video today not
sure why you need the shower mr stark
were you injured in the attack no but i
did spill my drink and it was a 26
mcallen so i'm pretty sure that's a war
crime drinking a vehicle excuse me sir
harry weddington british post the
british post that doesn't even exist
sure there was a tabloid called the post
that had a whopping five issues in 1998
but those crazy brits called their mail
the post so that didn't even make sense
we're watching you harry whittington at
least come up with a better fake name
whittington i think that's a real thing
since on the day of the attack his unit
was stationed 400 clicks away using the
term click come on to you military you
thought you could get away with going to
the metric system by saying a cool word
like click instead of kilometer not in
my america
ah i never liked that guy when did happy
turn into such an aggressive grouch is
happy named grumpy in this universe are
there other universes where he's sleepy
or sneezy release the dopey cut you're
butch i'm sundance just so we're clear
paul newman shaming this is my doctoral
thesis i developed plans for automated
combat drawing an easily searchable mit
doctoral thesis in a database that
pepper somehow hadn't been able to find
bullsh
you saved my life i'd like to return the
favor and giving him a job wasn't enough
of a returning the favor for you worst
case scenario will end up with the
world's most expensive gundam model you
joke but that model is about as gundam
as it gets they probably told some
lackey to design something that felt
like gundam and they were like or i
could just upload an actual gundam and
spend the rest of my days shopping for
hard to get 4k steelbooks on ebay crates
delegation drink breaks swipe and
scrunch disco dismemberment sparks
soldering staring punching excitement oh
oh no foreplay it's a waste of time
anyway
you take that back sir you take that
back now that i know you mean business
we can move on to the good stuff which
is why foreplay is so important [ __ ]
what are they teaching in schools these
days killmonger you got eyes on this
killmonger ah yes continue to vocalize
your ally's name so enemies can easily
hear smirt so smirt the amount of panic
firing happening in these metal close
quarters calls into question everyone's
intelligence including the writers who
allowed the dumb to ricochet around the
script stark r d is no joke the sonic
taser thing is legit yep stark r d will
provide you with whatever story
ammunition and plot armor you need need
black panther to die we'll bring back
the sonic taser it's like an easy button
for squeezing a bunch of complex plot
movements into 25 minutes these entirely
two large pockets sometimes the real
world sneaks into our fantasy
entertainment and the loss of chadwick
is honestly making this black panther
funeral hit on a pretty deep level sends
off for a legend gone too soon what do
you say to killers actually in this case
you could toast to having a killer robot
who instead of finishing the job when he
has the target in hand decides to toss
him out and play with him a little more
for reasons
your moves are his moves we call that
same versus same around here tony and
then we sent it fit character loses
clothing in a ridiculous way so the
audience can bask in the sexy hand we're
not complaining and the show will
pretend it's about the kill count tats
but that doesn't mean the real reason
isn't nakedly obvious cliche this
sequence did not start with 13 years
later which is how long it should have
taken for all these massive weapons to
have been created congratulations
lieutenant you just invented 21st
century warfare with what killer drones
we've been doing those since the 20th
century i know these ones walk instead
of fly but remind me again exactly how
that's an upgrade
yes
stealing daniel bryan's catchphrase
wakandans are full of surprises
what kind of vision i come with a gift
an offering of justice
sure but how did you get in here and why
exactly are the dora milaje meeting you
here in this oh so cinematic middle of
nowhere oh please they're built by
americans we'll be home in time for
lunch that's mericus the drones operate
via a hive matrix how does she know any
of this they spelled borg wrong also
these cars followed the flow of the
arrows past their parking spot and then
forced anyone behind them to wait while
they backed in like [ __ ] i want a
little bit more than that
a button a button the droids are cut off
from whatever nonsense matrix they use
but this easy button key fob [ __ ]
powers them up via a backup transmitter
where when how this episode is trying to
do all the narrative work of a full
movie but the condensed run time makes
it all feel unearned and silly a button
force field shields powering up on one
side and an army of droids with pointy
heads easily deactivated on the other
side this battle of naboos so hard i
think jar jar just became an official
member of the avengers killmonger leaps
from a legend lands on a war rhino at
the front of the pack and how exactly do
physics work in wakanda or better
question where did he jump from there's
no tall balcony behind him as he rides
away also i genuinely need a primer on
wakanda battle rhino use they're all
suited up for this skirmish with some
battle droids but in infinity war they
left them in the stables and yes i know
this is a different universe but that
doesn't make this any less confusing
does marvel even know how to end
anything without a big fighter battle
when do we get the marvel that ends with
a rom-com wedding or murder mystery
reveal or bollywood dancing number boy
it sure is nice of the war droids to
stop attacking so that our beloved
characters can have a battle bonding
beat we cut back to captain grumpy pants
as if he's been watching this whole
thing unfold but did he ever even get
the signal back did the easy button
somehow restore his view too despite
being outside of the shield i have no
idea how any of this works and i paid
for this with my existing disney plus
subscription so it's my right to know
every single detail venting your anger
on the letter e i'm getting heavy
screaming cowboy vibes off the watcher
here and now i'm sitting the show for
getting that i'm gonna go with song
stuck in my head again with this herb
you shall become
the next black panther drinking the
purple stuff instead of the sunny d
what how did you get in here better
question how did she turn herself around
in a dramatic reveal when murphy can't
touch the floor and her hands are in her
lap one minute in 45 seconds of opening
logos yes we're still mad no we won't
stop bringing it up and yes we will
still watch every damn second of content
disney puts out star wars episode opens
on stars cliche oh that's the wrong show
my bad you know what the cliche still
stands i've never been in the desert
waiting for an alien invasion before but
if i were i doubt i'd waste the car
battery by leaving the lights
or the on
this is it
for the
yes prematurely celebrating every single
shot until one eventually hits its mark
not only makes mockery of yourself darcy
but also of the prestigious american
institution that is the game of peanut
cup after seven episodes i might be
coming around on this animation style
but what i can't get past is the
inconsistent effort that seems to go
into creating the original actor's
likenesses i mean this is a pretty
spot-on animated version of kat dinnings
but jane foster here looks like she was
designed by someone who vaguely
remembers natalie portman from something
they were half watching several years
ago we're too late
the invasion has begun based on what
okay two years ago you saw the same
anomaly wipe out a star but how are you
getting alien invasion from that we find
out later that jane thinks this is
humanity's first contact with aliens so
why would she leap to this instead of
randomly occurring space phenomenon
welcoming anyone to vegas i suppose if
there's one place on earth where a group
of aliens can beam down directly in
front of you ominously threaten your
dull life and then pivot to an upbeat
party vibe without question it's las
vegas so the sin as always is pineapple
shirts more than battles won or lost
it's relationships that truly define a
hero it wouldn't be a true what if
episode if some sudden expositional
narration didn't put the hammer down on
the story just as it's starting to build
momentum go on tell me the thing you
could have told me during the opening
credits instead of the exact same master
marveling we've seen a hundred times
before odin sleeping on a penis-shaped
bed remember heimdall will be watching
wait what why is this a surprise to thor
heimdall's entire gig is based around
him being able to hear and see almost
everything in the nine realms well until
the plot needs him to turn a blind sword
anyway who's bright idea was it to keep
the [ __ ] infinity gauntlet down here
with all of the infinity stones already
inside it do you want to get dusted
because this is how you get dusted we
are going to the most backward backwater
planet that not even heimdall pays
attention to that is how this show is
going to explain why heimdall doesn't
notice thor causing havoc on earth thor
is just going to assume that heimdall
isn't paying attention to the most
boring 11 of the 9 realms he's tasked
with watching and you know what the
biggest sin is here he's [ __ ] right
yeah have a drink it never runs out hey
guys uh carl urban pulled out at the
last second should we just cut his
character out nah we're going for a
needless easter egg record so let's
leave him in but make sure he's
completely silent no one will notice
except those pesky youtubers and who
cares what they think
huzzah shouldn't there be more lasers
probing a flying cow imagine being so
whiny that you'd rather see a flying cow
over alien species being beamed in from
a dozen hovering spacecrafts imagine now
slap yourself in the face and be
grateful for what you have damn it
according to my dad the first
extraterrestrial to arrive was
him oh shut up the party arrived all at
the same time we all saw it oh yes the
girl loses her mind over a handsome man
flinging his hair around cliche next
you're gonna tell me she abandons her
research to party with the hot man falls
in love instantly and gets petty about
him not calling her immediately
wait that actually happens
me man i had like a hundred sins
i expected him to look more like like
what e.t and less like a hottie mcscotty
beach buddy ken old school abercrombie
catalog i could go on i'd really prefer
if you didn't quirky mcflurry comic
reliefy awkward von speaks a lot you can
make first contact with i don't know
that guy he looks like a loser
big talk coming from um
man these forced howard the duck easter
eggs are like quack cocaine to some
people not me though i'm nowhere near
that mallard justed also neither jane or
darcy who have never been exposed to
alien life think twice about this wise
quacking duck in a suit
topaz what do i always say i love cake
yes they actually managed to get jeff
goldblum back to play the grand master
and this was the best thing they could
think for him to say did you build this
all by yourself excuse me i happen to be
an astrophysicist with multiple phd so
no i now pronounce your toxin and a duck
anatodiphilia the hangover part thor led
by the main instigator thor of asgard
who's now taken to the skies what
he left did he did he even leave a note
our multiple phd holding genius female
lead goes from a dog admission to save
the world to why doesn't he love me
quicker than steve rogers comes to save
the day in the captain carter episode a
beeper my dad has one he's a podiatrist
wait are you guys calling a podiatrist
yes because in this universe all beepers
lead to podiatry everyone say waffles
waffles who wants to have a waffle
picture we say cheese so it looks like
we're smiling not waffles nobody wants
to have the oh face in a picture
tell me is that butt ugly popsicle stick
talking to me
characters pretend to be enemies to
build tension but end up being friends
cliche
you are the absolute best which is why
marvel will continue to put this
character into as many scenes as
possible this particular scene allowed
them to cross off audience wants to see
loki as a frost giant from their list my
brother from another mother man i mean
that i mean ah brothers forever brothers
forever
but why and how why does the show feel
determined to change everything and at
the same time nothing at all wasn't this
alternate universe created precisely
because thor didn't grow up with loki
okay maybe they became friends later in
life but again i ask why and how in case
you confused it with france wait why are
the names of countries printed on top of
the countries themselves what an oddly
specific consequence of thor growing up
as an only child this one's for fury
captain marvel eventually moves this
battle out to the sticks but regardless
she still decided to start this
super-powered fight with a literal god
in the middle of a densely populated
area as if to guarantee maximum
collateral damage still learning those
man of steel lessons nearly a decade
later i see
smooth move bro
amarang get it yes we get it and i will
thank you to leave the grown worthy
portmanteaus to the professional bro
thor buddy fowl says the man who did the
exact same thing to her only moments
earlier oh yes the same versus same
battle where every blow means nothing
and the tension is as dull as a butter
knife
gun oh you're maverick is your ego
writing checks that your skills can't
cash the ability to quote pop culture
references does not make you intelligent
i mean funny who are you darcy big fan
how can she be a big fan of someone
she's never heard of for all she knows
this is still sahel's on-call podiatrist
you know i've got a crown too
and we both like fire man
come on let's see what turn up the heat
on this thing a galmatophilia why do you
insist on crushing my mellow oh loosen
up have fun smile a little thor survives
this ready to fire on your command fire
in five apparently it's nearly
impossible to have a finale to any kind
of action adventure story without
deploying the [ __ ] countdown to
destruction that is inevitably beaten in
the nick of time this time it feels
especially egregious considering we have
no idea why maria is choosing to launch
the nuclear strike early and we also
have no cause to believe that said
nuclear launch will actually have any
deleterious effect on either the
attendant target or the innocent
friendly combatant stand down we're done
here
we never get to fire the nukes allowing
one of your characters to lament the
fact that they are unable to deploy
environment devastating skin melting
civilization ending weapons for the sake
of a punchline my suggestion start in
the corners clean your way outward if
you start in the corners how are you
supposed to go outward aren't the
corners the most outwardly point in most
rooms honestly thor i think you're
better off without her help so
oh hello mother welcome to our study
group i hope heimdall gets an almighty
asgardian ass whooping when odin wakes
up not only did he entirely miss half of
the mcu congregating on one planet for
the party of the millennia he also set
the bifrost velocity to plot convenience
so that frigga's transit to earth would
take the exact amount of time that thor
required to clean up the entire planet
and put together a complete [ __ ]
syllabus to prove he was studying the
whole time you called my mother on me
that wasn't the cool thing to do jane's
intention wasn't to rat him out it was
the war and figure that her son's life
could be in danger knowing that she
would likely be able to intervene in
some way but i suppose we'll just gloss
over that for the sake of establishing
this romance that essentially puts this
universe back to square one as if
nothing happened and then oh dear
perhaps i spoke too soon wait what the
biggest betrayal behind these extended
opening credits is the knowledge that
marvel has a track record for slipping
in easter eggs or changing things when
we least expect it this means that you
can guarantee the one time i decide to
skip them something universe shakingly
marvelous will happen like the sudden
appearance of boba fett the retconning
of a key character death or the
long-awaited reveal of how hawkeye's
arrow was able to kill thor that one
time we've seen this before my thoughts
on watching the opening credits for the
eighth time somehow made its way into
the episode black widow and hawkeye
should be thanking their lucky stars
that the ultron bots like to play with
their food instead of immediately
cooking it with their pew pews i mean
come on she's on a [ __ ] motorbike and
they can literally fly is their range
really so poor that it isn't even worth
them firing off a few shots
[Music]
i'd be far more impressed with this
admittedly incredible archery if i could
actually watch hawkeye do the math it
would take to make these shots from this
point of view it looks like he just
blind fires them into the air hoping
that a favorable wind and the generous
storyboarder will guide the arrows to
their intended targets why isn't all of
hawkeye's armor and other clothing made
out of the same stuff that the cloak of
cloaking is made out of yeah yeah i'm
sure there's some bs reason like it's
too difficult to make or it isn't
durable enough to use his armor and to
that i say the following we are in a
universe containing actual wizards and
sorcerers the [ __ ] murder bots run in
one at a time to engage in hand-to-hand
combat instead of remaining airborne and
unleashing a torrent of death from above
thus easily killing the squishy
non-superpowered human come on i feel
like you should know me by now puns
aren't really my style did she just
shame puns
did she just shame puns
so you really think the secret to taking
down ultron is here it's russia hawkeye
secrets were the national pastime be
that as it may all guy's question still
stands i hope she's basing this hunch on
more than just the stereotype the
russians keep secrets because that's all
the racist the end of the world began
with one man's dream show will spend the
next 36 seconds expositing to us what we
already know in our universe we beat
ultron in this universe ultron one i
mean it's in the dag-blame title marvel
ultronoman skip it's evolution only a
primitive mind would fail to see the
distinction no offense to ross marquand
i'm sure he's a hell of a guy but the
best thing about ultron is the voice of
james spader so here's a sin for making
an ultron episode without using the
spades we're too late he did it laura
[ __ ] bucky oh my bad sorry whenever a
character wistfully exclaims someone's
name in anguish i appear to have been
trained to assume it's bucky this one's
on you marvel ultron appears to have
gained the ability to apparate a badass
cape at will which seems like a
perfectly valid use of the most powerful
resources in the known universe listen
skynet i've seen the killer robot movie
and i gotta say i really don't think it
needs a sequel captain marvel is a dick
to t2 the methods that heroes choose to
deal with big bads is so often baffling
to me captain marvel has the power of a
million nukes at her fingertips so why
does she even need xandar's molten core
to kill ultron damn it flies ass into
space away from the planet's population
sure he can still kill everyone from out
there but at least you haven't put him
in a position where he can immediately
explode the planet from the inside out
at last
hey guys i know ultron doesn't need an
atmosphere to work but sound does he
became aware of another he became aware
of the
i see you bringing the author into his
own narrative also known as stephen king
also this is a super cool twist but i
feel like it breaks so much about how
we've been told this voyeuristic
storytelling works doesn't the watcher
surprise suggest that this is the first
time he's seeing these events unfold if
that's the case how can he be telling us
about it in the past tense as if he
knows the ending on the other hand if
these are events that he's replaying why
is it only this time through the story
that ultron becomes aware of the watcher
why does the watcher even need to be
watching for this spontaneous hyper
awareness to happen damn it this whole
thing makes less sense than rick moranis
and spaceballs watching the cassette
tape of spaceballs to figure out what
rick moranis and spaceballs will do next
there is still hope for this universe
you'll have to excuse me if i have
trouble believing that saving the entire
multiverse from the destructive hands of
an omniscient entity infused with
infinity stones now rests solely on the
shoulders of two people whose
superpowers consist of an aptitude for
gymnastics
and above average hand-eye coordination
if we want to take down ultron we need
an ai that can combat his code well now
it sounds like she knows exactly what
they're looking for in here so i can
only assume that the files in this place
are organized entirely at random or else
why wouldn't she go straight to the
break glass in case of emergent ai box
grab it grab it no
way yes way because you black widow
appear to have been gifted with just
enough knowledge to make your way to
these archives and accidentally yourself
into the box containing the solution to
all your problems while still giving the
impression that you didn't actually have
a clue what you were looking for in the
first place it might not be the watcher
but someone is definitely giving her a
hand here they really didn't there's
still hope
oh no i still have no clue why all of
these multiverses appear to be taking
place in real time now that black widow
and hawkeye have found the key to
ultron's destruction shouldn't that be
problem solved why does the watcher have
to wait for all of this to play out
roll commercial oh sorry that's the
wrong show you know what [ __ ] it they're
all the same roll the commercials
francis really how did i not know that
the character discovers her coworker's
middle name and thinks it's funny he or
she didn't already have that information
cliche and i've ruined a lot of laptops
this way and while i get that it's the
point having an open container of liquid
around any electronics will always get
you a sin clinton frances barton the
ultron heife mind appears to be out of
range zola can't connect to ultron but
can he at least connect to the ultron
drones that are here right now surely
these things come with some sort of
bluetooth
what am i saying bluetooth never works
how long has hawkeye been holding onto
that arrow and why doesn't he just have
15 of those bad boys instead of all
these basic ass ones i told you i don't
want to fight anymore and see it's
different because black widow isn't the
one falling to her death and it's
hawkeye so now she has to watch her
friend die and that probably shouldn't
mean something but now i hate everything
is that how this is supposed to work oh
but anything is possible in a multiverse
exactly like for instance there are now
zero stakes in any of these properties
because you can just bring back whomever
you want to whenever they want to do
whatever they want and the world can
feel a collective geek asm when alfred
molina utters the words hello peter all
of it will happen but none of it will
matter happy now marvel happy also is
the show saying that there's actually a
physical barrier between the area that
the watcher enjoys his peeping and the
universes that he's peeping on because
in the spirit of non-interference i just
think that's a design flaw being if his
scope would be able to avoid why does he
even need a physical space at all by
possessing all six infinity stones
ultron has the ability to bend time
space and even reality itself the
watcher in turn has access to every
recorded event in the past present and
future of the multiverse
let's stick to the good old alternating
beams of color witty retorts and general
fisticuffs to settle this battle between
the two most powerful beings known to
exist isn't this more fun than just
watching
and to be honest it's a lot less creepy
on your part ultron would be the big
winner at tv sense what if marvel
decided we didn't need over 90 seconds
of narcissistic self-stimulation just to
prove that we're watching a marvel
property and yes we've send it every
time and yes if you're watching the
season long video this might feel like
you keep seeing it over and over again
and yes that's exactly the point fine
i've got the shield you've got the sword
more like knives but cute word play not
my black widow would be terrible at
cinemasins cause that's not q wordplay
that was a forced and incorrect
comparative analysis cute wordplay would
be if she said fine i'll be your human
shield but you have no superpowers and
are useless addition to the team i mean
i think that's super cute nothing good
has ever followed the phrase bernard in
accounting nothing not bernard in
accounting just found a million dollar
tax write-off not bernard and accounting
has identified the employee who's been
stealing from the company not bernard in
accounting was hanging out at a best buy
and just scored us all ps5s i thought
you were more than just a shield i'm a
pretty good dancer too non-funny
non-important non-sequiturs also
henchman has the drop on the protagonist
but instead of shooting them and
eliminating them immediately hinchman
instead chooses to drop weapon and fight
hand to hand cliche are you seeing that
a valuable question considering that if
he did the watcher would be permanently
changing these timelines in fact we seem
to get confirmation that others do see
him in other universes and yet the show
will remain completely uninterested in
exploring these ideas when there's a
forced and unearned team-up plot to get
to dairy queen ah come on relax son
it'll all be over in a thousand years or
so this is the only scene that contains
one mr kurt vogel russell
stopping a living planet this easily
star-lord t'challa leader of the
ravagers and lost prince of wakanda you
have been chosen the watcher picking his
fantasy team reminds me of the first big
brother episode every season where the
players react being chosen to be in the
house so here's a sin for being anything
like a reality show and another one for
tricking me into admitting i watch big
brother gamora survivor of sakaar and
destroyer of thanos who did what to who
now and yes i'm aware this character was
from an episode that got cut from the
season for some reason and that doesn't
make this introduction any less baffling
or our investment in her any list who
gives a sh thing eric stevens
killmonger tony stark's former protege
and killer
you
have been chosen killmonger killmonger
why pick the one most likely to destroy
your team and have some sort of ulterior
plan you know give me the nonsense they
try to sell later about the watcher
knowing the future possible futures or
whatever because that doesn't jive with
either his attitude or actions in other
parts of the series in this episode the
simple fact is that the watcher is
terrible at picking his team drafts
worse than the cleveland cavs nobody
messes with vegas actually doesn't
everyone mess with vegas isn't that kind
of vegas thing i will say it is nice for
getting some captain carter without
having to shoehorn steve rogers into it
some oh come on the pub facade was my
idea i read about it in your biography i
hope you like it i only want to make
peggy comfortable though the rest of you
or have a beer i don't give a sh
yes
you may think thor is happy he's getting
a beer but he's actually exclaiming his
excitement that he managed to subtly
sneak in chekhov's plot convenient robot
head into this strange purgatorial pub
come on get a new trick man what was the
first trick did the watcher pull a bunny
out of his hat i always miss the good
stuff
you are
the guardians of the multiverse look i
know that's not the title of the show or
episode but that moment rolled
commercials so hard it's where they just
accidentally changed the title of the
show to guardians of the multiverse then
i would i wouldn't do that my lady to be
fair thor probably wouldn't listen to
anything strange says but you'd still
think strange would try a little harder
than an i wouldn't do that considering
thor could very easily be walking to his
death we're in mind telling us what
we're up against and make sure you say
it loud enough and clear enough for the
audience who are probably mindlessly
scrolling through tick tock right now
but might need a little bit of this
exposition six stones of near
unfathomable power each controlling an
essential aspect of our existence
infinity stones you say do tell
also you have to love the stones on
marvel to be like hey we want to combine
our anthology series into a shared
narrative for the final episode how are
we feeling about a group of superheroes
teaming up to fight an evil power with
access to all six infinity stones this
is just like the school year i turned in
the exact same book report for every
book but just swapped out character
names and titles and just as lazy is
there a universe of chinese food that
has alternate dimension delivery tommy's
getting rumbly everyone said no thor
could be worse than end game thor and
what if said hold my ale the chandelier
survives this can i ask what happened
same thing that happened to you
love is love the code name of the super
soldier serum because what happened to
captain carter was the super soldier
serum it's a protection spell you're
welcome and it will protect you from the
most powerful being in the multiverse
until the plot needs it not to now we
know doc's role in the guardians of the
multiverse is to provide literal plot
armor wait how is ultra ultron using the
stones outside of his universe i thought
we established that was a no-go and loki
and yes i'm aware one of the writers
said something about all the universes
becoming like one big soupy universe and
that ultron was a powered being via the
stone so he wasn't technically using
them but that sounds like some sort of
wishing for more wishes bullsh just
admit you wanted a cool multiversal
battle so you broke your own rules
marvel usually you people are much
easier to kill yeah here's the thing
they are easy to kill you can literally
rewrite reality with one of those stones
so just snap them out of existence and
be done with it as yondu says never
doubt sticky fingers yep the most
cosmically powered being of all time
undone by pickpocketing god bless you
marvel god bless your little hearts also
oh no not the soul stone his only
remaining abilities are to control minds
time space power in the entire fabric of
reality also also those aren't fingers
that's your palm
what you've been hiding that the entire
time i know we've talked already about
how great thor would be at tv sins but
damn it i should have just let him write
the script i could have spent the day
catching up and i know what you did last
summer i i mean love island i mean um
look a cyclops out of all the things
that could help stop ultron the best
strange could come up with is zombies
zombies even george a romero would tell
you that's a terrible [ __ ] idea there
are three people you trust in the
universe and i count myself lucky enough
to be one of them well
we must be close
i believe the term is bff and i believe
the term is bss someone drops in and the
only thing it takes to trust them is let
me make sure i have this right they tell
you to trust them i can destroy galaxies
with the thought ah then why don't you
destroy the guardians with a thought i'm
done pointing out all the stupid ways
ultron is not using his powers to end
this quickly like puny pew pewing the
dove injures instead of just manifesting
a thousand foot arm and grabbing the
stone but because the rest of this
episode is basically a somehow even
battle i'm adding 50 cents here so i can
rest easy tonight
wait
what no clue man you're on your own
don't give him a shot yeah this is so
cool she's punching him and then she's
punching him and then she's
so now both of these time stones are
fighting each other in the same universe
beyond the breaking the rules part of
this if all stones could be used why
doesn't the watcher just go snag the
infinity stones from all other universes
and that way everyone can have their own
matching set i'm just saying there were
a lot of options that would probably
serve everyone better than this crew
trying to karate chop ultron to death
deus ex octana gotta love it when your
fancy restrainment spell depends on
actual manual force to maintain it hope
chris pratt doesn't show up it doesn't
feel over every single person's reaction
to the movie dune somehow makes it into
the episode of course the crusher was
designed to destroy the stones on my
world and your episode was designed to
be in this season of the show so that
any of this would make sense but we
can't always get what we want i guess
also if the crusher wasn't able to crush
those stones why did it give indicator
lights for each stone as if it was
accomplishing its goal is it in the
habit of claiming it's done amazing
things that it hasn't done stonecrusher
should run for president
now isn't that convenient this one's for
you clinton blackeye here shoots this
arrow before union jacked jumps from
approximately the same distance arrows
out of a compound boat can go upwards of
200 miles per hour and captain carter
wins that race by leaping from a
building's rooftop also cap lands on the
ground before hawk widow does which
somehow makes even less sense
considering she spent a few moments
playing piggyback with papatron also
also there are probably a good dozen
easier ways to get the ai into ultron
that don't involve an arrow but marvel
really wants us to believe hawkeye
served a purpose could someone explain
please i gave him a virus a nasty one
what if the ending of independence day
made sense nope no need to explain this
just hold the robot head out and blammo
all the suit and powers just fly on over
if anyone questions it we'll just call
it nano transference or something
they'll buy it all next question hydra
never died it just mutated that explains
the stomach face it does not someone
needs to attend to them if that pocket
dimension cracks if they escape i'll
watch well thank goodness steven is able
to watch who else possibly could have
oversaw that task it's not like watches
in any character's name or any wait
pulling a saint elsewhere you're not my
natasha but something tells me you have
her spirit well that was wrapped up
nicely sweet mid-credit scene back in
captain carter's world this obviously
means she'll be getting her own show
without having to worry about steve
rogers being forced into everything she
the hydra stomper
yeah and there's someone inside damn it
there are
no strings on me
hang on i'll be right back i'll be right
back hey vasquez
have you ever been mistaken for a man no
have you is this nuclear no no no no
this sucker's electrical don't say it
don't you say left come on
steam
steve
you are where you choose to be
[Music]
hi
i noticed your glass was getting a
little low so i took the liberty of
bringing you another apple martini
and i couldn't help but notice you look
a lot like my next girlfriend
thanks try to listen so do you like
cuban food
hmm
that is sort of an okie after birth
hold it hold it is this a kissing book
tony stark was able to build this in a
cave
with a box of scraps well i'm sorry i'm
not tony stark
that's gonna leave a mark look at me
sure i'm the captain now
that's it
no more mr nice duck
thank you i'm very popping y'all you
don't belong down there with them you
belong up here with us with your family
there's always room for family i gotta
get some of that green stuff
no
not that green stuff
all you did was show me
the universe i should have been a better
father to you dewey i wish
i spent more time playing catch with you
and less time training my body and mind
to kill you in a machete fight
there was an idea
to bring together a group of this guy
single-handedly ruined the word mother
you know how hard that is to do
then you should know i'm not afraid of a
big swing merrell
swing away
so you like donut day
you know what they call a quarter
pounder with cheese and apparently they
don't call it a quarter pounder with
cheese they call it the royale which
before we get started
does anyone want to get out
oh gill's in a lot of trouble wow
even while rotting he smells like
lavender and your father's smelt of
elderberries which is why i have to ask
what's in the box what's in the box
you never cared about hope hey i didn't
even know that [ __ ] i think you
should just rush the podium like a
contestant on the price is right the
price is wrong [ __ ]
we're okay
you're okay you're gonna be okay
say the word christine and i will give
you the world you you want the moon just
say the word and i'll throw a lasso
around and pull it down
well
we're back
in the car again
i only require more power with great
power
and get back to the house in no time
[Music]
do you guys just not have horror movies
in wakanda what do you mean you people
how do you stay so
upbeat
i can charm dogs
gypsy witchcraft and those i can't charm
i can kill with my own hands
you lured innocent people to their
deaths all in the name of love you can
make any story work i once convinced the
woman that i was kevin costner
what's our fuel gauge reading fuel gauge
29 2900 angle cock's closed handbrake's
knocked off we're gonna have to walk
through
that
[Music]
nibble my ear for luck but don't you
worry about that i brought receipts
thank you
and this is my receipt for your receipt
we'll be like butch and sundance well
the way i figured we need to fight or
give
if we give we go to jail i've been there
already
oh oh no foreplay
you know what it's a waste of time
anyway no no no no more foreplay
ouch time
tommy
how's it peeping
[Music]
you got knocked the [ __ ] out man do you
know how to use that thing
yeah
pointy end goes into the other men
rhynox maximize
guess who's coming to dinner
once upon a time in a faraway land
a young prince lived in a shining castle
although he had everything his heart
desired
the prince was spoiled
hollywood movies did not prepare me for
this shouldn't there be more lasers
probing why does everyone always assume
that what am i doing am i harvesting
farts how much can i learn from an ass
describe what marcellus wallace looks
like what say what again say what again
yeah yeah but your scientists were so
preoccupied with whether or not they
could they didn't stop to think they
should
i'll
chase around the moons of nivea and
round the antares maelstrom and round
perditions flames before i give him up
hi everybody
[Applause]
engage no contact protocol
no hand shall touch my body
i am locutous
is futile your life as it has been is
over
from this time forward you will service
us
i'm going to bring about peace in our
time yeah you say peace
i kind of think you mean the other thing
there's still hope
yeah
oh no
welcome to the cafe 80s where it's
always morning in america even in the
afternoon at noon
clinton francis hey don't take any [ __ ]
from him cunningham
how tough can he be
with a name like francis
[Music]
when you die i'm going to laminate your
skeleton and pose you in the lobby you
want me to say it say it
is he wearing a parachute
no
no he wasn't star-lord t'challa leader
of the ravagers and lost prince of
wakanda you
have been chosen you choo-choo choose me
what is that
that is an overhead projector do you
ever use it anymore no not really yeah
is there a universe of chinese food that
has alternate dimension delivery tommy's
getting rumbly i'm so rumbly in my
tumbly i propose a toast true love is
hard to find
sometimes you think you have true love
and then you catch the early flight home
from
san diego and a couple of new people
jump out of your bathroom blindfolded
like a goddamn magic show ready to
double team your girlfriend
release the kraken